in washington it started off 1-0 they're
now one and two and dwayne haskins had
four turnovers yesterday two fumbles one
was recovered by him one by the other
team three interceptions and yesterday
ron rivera said he's not going to pull
the plug on dwayne haskins based on one
game however however a caveat was
applied by coach rivera today here he is
there is i mean again and and and and
you brought up the point and it's a very
good point is that there are guys in
that locker room that are playing well
enough for us to win and again we have
to make sure everybody is playing well
enough to win at that point and there is
there there is there is a a cut-off
point for me there is
where the cutoff point is remains to be
seen but the question becomes if and
when dwayne haskins is bench didn't look
that's significant because this is the
15th overall pick from the 2019 draft
new coaching staff new regime in
washington new culture new name new
everything if he ends up getting benched
i don't know what you do with him after
that do you keep him around as a very
expensive backup do you find someone
that may want to trade for him that's a
after the season type thing unless
there's somebody that would swoop in
during the season and want him i doubt
that happens before the tuesday after
week eight but then the question is is
it kyle allen who has the equity build
up with ron rivera from their time
together last year in carolina or is it
alex smith one of the all-time great
comeback stories in the nfl after having
that serious broken leg the infection
that nearly ended his life and or
resulted in the amputation of that leg
if he comes back in place and he can
play like he did two years ago if that's
the case then this team is still very
much alive in a division where one and
two has them tied for first place
sharing
yeah no question about it and that's the
thing they play in the nfc east where
where they're tied for the lead but you
know if you look at this washington team
that defense is very good but this is
not a team that's going to contend this
year they're building they're in the
first year with ron rivera they didn't
get the real offseason program that they
needed with him i think he's going to
build a great program and to me
you let dwayne haskins play this year
you see what you have in him you decide
if he is your quarterback of the future
by letting him play not sending him on
the bench and we all want to see alex
smith play as you said one of the
greatest comeback stories in nfl history
we never even thought he would get to
this point and he has we'd love to see
him play but i think as an organization
you have to know what you have in dwayne
haskins and i'm not sure they know yet
he didn't play very many snaps in
college until his last year there then
he played a bunch of snaps and then he
was on and off last year and looked
really good in those last six quarters
and now this year you look at him he has
four touchdowns three interceptions and
is 6.2 yards per attempt is 30th in the
nfl so you know they've got to figure
out what they have in him and i know the
pet cat is kyle allen he's not your
quarterback of the future you got
nothing in him he's going to be a backup
for you from now on he knows your
offense i don't see him playing i think
it's either alex smith or dwayne haskins
but i think you stick with haskins even
if you have a chance to win the division
and you think one of those other
quarterbacks is better i think you take
your lumps as ron rivera said yesterday
with dwayne haskins and figure out if
you need to go a different direction
next year
at one point rivera said today that the
other players on offense deserve better
which
that is more damning than saying there's
a cutoff point and it just feels like
the challenge has been set for dwayne
haskins almost like in the off-season
where dwayne haskins was the subject of
comments from ron rivera suggesting
rivera was ambivalent about him and
maybe he wasn't sold on and i think that
was intended to prod dwayne haskins to
get himself into better shape to work
harder to try to advance his game to the
proverbial next level he got a lot of
praise after week one for the halftime
speech that haskins gave to the team
while rivera was getting a planned iv as
part of his cancer treatment and they
went out and they erased a 17 point
deficit they were down 10 at the half
they won the game everything's great two
weeks later everything's not great it's
amazing how quickly that pendulum can
can shift in the nfl but but look you've
got to win games and if you don't win
games these questions are going to
linger and if you have four turnovers as
a quarterback that's not going to keep
you on the field and that raises some
real questions about the team and again
the good news they're in the nfc east
now even though there's an extra playoff
team now in each conference i still
don't like the fact that there are four
or four team divisions per conference i
don't have a solution other than maybe
expanding
the league from 32 to 36 and having
16
divisions with that work three 16
divisions per conference and then you
have 36 total teams at least you take
away one of these junk garbage potential
playoff berths based upon being the the
least of four bad teams but that's what
the nfc east is looking like this year
just like it was last year and meanwhile
the nfc west is murderers row seemingly
from top to bottom although arizona
would suggest otherwise after its
performance against the lions yesterday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports